in the beginning there was darkness and
then bang
the quest for answers begins here in a
cloud of dust and gas stars blazing in a
place we call the universe
you're not trying to have sex with me
right now are you right now but I think
maybe in about 45 minutes life on the
edge its hydrogen the lightest simplest
most abundant element in the universe in
fact in our galaxy there are 400 and
billion galaxies just in our galaxy and
how can it be that all human beings on
earth
oh there lives - Alex Filippenko though
a supernova is visually very very bright
the visible light is only 1% of 1% of 1%
of 1% of 1% of 1% 110 thousand of the
entire energy emitted by this colossal
explosion
giving birth to an endless expanding ass
mop and even it won't leave the curve
back around so you won't be able to see
it from the outside hence the name coal
there's always gravity pulling you back
down the universe where the heat rises
to a scorching zero million degrees
right now this dance will end in
catastrophe one teaspoonful of neutron
star material would weigh cerillion tons
so imagine you take a star
you just made yourself a neutral stone
but how were these stars born if you've
got you've got a star the amount of
pressure pushing out on the star just
matches the amount of gravity pulling in
on the star and they Bank and it can sit
there and happily until something
changes the heat begins to soar the
cloud spins into a flattening the
pillars of creation others much larger
than hotter in size definitely matters
squeezing that amount of mass into such
a small space rattles the heavens it's a
lot of syllables but it just means it's
hot there and smoke please become big a
catastrophic explosion small cool red
stars like this one Sirius B which can
be seen only faintly aside its companion
the Sirius degeneracy pressure takes
over so it's really amazing stuff a
white dwarf is the final stage in the
life of a sun-like star but it's not
quite dead yet I like to call white
dwarfs [ __ ] stars scientists are
still studying the aftermath of the
explosion early those that they think
supernova 2006gy now has a lot to teach
you
won't be able to use that
and if you give up or let go or the rope
breaks gravity immediately wins and you
fall by combining the neutrons with the
two neutrons and turning them into
neutrons you now have an object which is
made almost entirely out of neutrons and
gravity wins oh there lives to Alex
Filippenko though a supernova is
visually very very bright the visible
light is a
that will be the fate of our son and
that's the essence of what makes a star
I start